all right so welcome to installation
number 21 in the worlds of speculative
fiction series here today we're looking
at CL Katherine who sealed Moore who
also wrote under a ton of other
pseudonyms interestingly enough before I
actually started doing research I didn't
connect some of the stories that I've
read with CL more so we'll talk about
some of that and why she she did that a
little bit later on she is you know she
was alive until fairly recently but she
didn't write science fiction much at
least four four stories after her
husband and collaborator hundred cook
nerd died and said she wrote for
television and she actually preferred
doing that so it's writing sci-fi with
him and she should live for quite a
while after that but she didn't do much
writing past really the you know the the
50s so she's known for the Pulte era
sort of the Golden Age of science
fiction and fantasy and Weird Tales
so she really fits in well with this
this speculative fiction series what I
wanted to do you know I've got the the
biography here for you I don't actually
have like a some quotes as I often do
because there's not much online
available from her in terms of
interviews or things like then I did
find one interview where she talked
about you know why she likes writing for
TV and how she got interested in that
sci-fi there was there was a big you
know sort of reflections on what she's
doing I didn't find a bit in this best
of co more ya know authors afterward and
said before word she has after work so
so there's there's that and the themes
that I wanted to focus on besides sort
of the worlds that she creates were the
centrality of emotions in her work
- Sadie about going beyond the limits of
the imagination on that aesthetic
versus involvement and things she's got
a lot of interesting stuff about time
travel but she doesn't give us time
travel paradoxes the way a lot of
authors do so time travel actually works
for her and then we also wanted to talk
about this this whole business of doing
a collaborative and pseudonymous
pseudonymous sir didymus the work that
that she did that led me to realize that
she's actually written a lot more than
that I thought she had so you know
before that we've got we've got her her
biography and you know you notice she's
born in Indianapolis she's a Midwestern
or she goes to Indiana University for a
short time she actually drops out
because it's the depression and so she's
fortunate enough to be able to find a
job as a secretary in a bank in
Indianapolis she's judging rates and
very interestingly in the afterword
about that she says that here it is yeah
I lived in a large Midwestern city the
depression of the 30s was rampant over
the land so I was snatched for my
sophomore year at the State University
and crammed into a business school - one
of the rudiments of shorthand typing by
incredible good fortune before I
finished the course a job opening and a
large Bank loomed up and I leaped in it
unprepared but eager and then she says
in parentheses in those days you didn't
mess around you've loved prayed and
grabbed that's kind of a nice way of
framing it and so she started working on
a bank and that's when she gets
introduced to science fiction she's been
reading other stuff before that but
she's you know there's there's a
magazine stand across the street and so
on her lunch breaks she goes over and
you know checks out these magazines that
have like you know Weird Tales and
astounding these things that we call
pulse and she starts reading oh she
loves them and she said it in led to
this interesting conflict because her
mother thought these are complete trash
you know you shouldn't be reading this
this garbage you're polluting your mind
but apparently her mother wasn't you
know quite strong enough to totally put
her foot down and she had to you know
eventually recognized that that Kath
Katherine was gonna read what she wanted
to read and she said I love this stuff
and in the interview the answer well
what did you really like about science
fiction she said it was escapist you
know who wouldn't want to go to Mars
instead of being stuck in Indianapolis
in the middle of the depression hey you
know if you think about what
Indianapolis was like at that time
Indiana was was essentially a clamp-on
state all the way from the 20s into the
30s
you know both political parties were
sort of in the pockets of the Klan that
it was it was a pretty repressive
society to be in so I last linting in
the 30s in thing could be yeah yeah
wouldn't surprise me it was you know I
mean a lot of a lot of the states that
would be like the one party would be
like the in the south it was the
Democrat Party in the north they'd offer
the Republicans who were aligned with
the Klan in India in Indiana was both
parties so so thoroughly permeated the
new clan the clan that rose in the 20s
where it was really tied in with sort of
like respectable businessmen it was no
longer the kind of organization that had
been in its original incarnation and
they were pinching themselves almost
like you know sort of a tougher version
of the Elks Club so she you know she
liked science fiction I think in part
because it offered something quite
different and then she starts she starts
writing and her very first story
shambleau which is a great story
she you know she sends it off to Weird
Tales because that's where she you know
I think it's because smart you know if
you if you're an author you send stuff
to the places that you like to read from
and so she does that there's a big story
about how like when it came in it was so
earth-shaking that the the editor took a
day off declared shablow her main
interest and it was
fact that they paid her 100 bucks for it
which was a lot of money at that time
and so she was like I think I could do
this this writing thing and and she's
got a you know interesting discussion in
the end of this about how she came up
with John blow and came up with this
Northwest Smith character apparently
she'd written correspondence once to a
guy NW Smith right she was like that
sounds kind of cool so she was she was
somebody who would take what she you
know gotten over here and over here and
over here and we even together into a
story but what was really remarkable
from you know why the story was so
important is emotion wasn't something
that was really discussed much at early
sci-fi I think you can say it wasn't
really horror you know Lovecraft is
somebody big at the time that that she's
ready Lovecraft did talk about that but
Lovecraft writes about men's emotions
you know aimless terror at this and that
he doesn't well in Lovecraft doesn't
handle women very well it's not even I
mean it's kind of a misogynist in some
respects from from the perspective of
the present but it I think it's more
like he just doesn't really deal with
women much in his inspection but more
does so she starts publishing and you
notice like all these these stories are
popping out so she's she's quite
successful but she says interestingly
again it missed this father's afterward
that if Shaun blow hand sold she would
have just give him up she had others
talking again so it happened to work out
and she just kept writing more she had a
character that she could work with them
black thirst is another really good one
that's starting out and then then she
starts writing about jor-el of jury
another another great character of hers
that we're going to talk about with the
black gods kiss and Jerome eats magic
already in like 3435 and by 1936 she
meets him
Kutner Kutner thinks that she's a guy he
writes to he writes her thinking that
that she's a guy and that he's going to
have a nice friendly conversation finds
out that she's a woman they started
having you know connections with each
other and you know become romantically
involved and then they started in 1937
writing together they start
collaborating they find that they really
worked well then he's got certain
strengths and certain weaknesses she's
got certain strengths and certain
weaknesses and they they kind of mesh
together so by 1940 they actually get
get married and they begin publishing
some of this stuff under pseudonyms
nobody actually knows in the scholarship
who is more responsible for certain
works there there's a theory that Lois
Padgett is more her and and lawrence
O'Donnell is more him but it could be
the opposite nobody's quite sure there
are people who have talked about like
spending time with them and seeing that
work at the same typewriter that he
would do a shift and then she would you
know he wouldn't he would go and like
take a nap or something she would go to
the typewriter same story start typing
away
and they would work their stuff together
like that sled that's pretty amazing you
know I mean nowadays with word
processing it would be a lot easier to
do that right but to do it on a single
typewriter that would be quite difficult
so you notice there's like consistent
publishing for years and years she talks
about how much they they actually made
at first they're getting about a cent of
word and then when they're writing
together they got half a cent a word and
so there was kind of you know you the
longer the story the better for you you
know the more words he could pack in
there the more money you can make and
and at first she said it was quite
difficult
you know they in 1940 they decided they
were both going to be full-time writers
and she said it was it was a very hard
scrabble existence for a while but then
it started paying off and eventually
they moved to Santa Monica and
open up other opportunities for them
they start studying at the University of
Southern California they're still
writing and eventually she graduates
from USC and not long after they get a
film script or an out film triplet that
television script Henri dives has a
heart attack and you notice she really
doesn't do much writing after that at
least not for for science fiction
magazines instead she takes over his
writing course that he's got at USC and
starts writing for television and in the
interview the one interview that I saw
with her she talks about why she
preferred television writing plus might
sound kind of strange she said it was so
collaborative no you know she's already
been doing this incredibly collaborative
work with the person she's been doing it
with his death television writing was
was this collaborative process she said
you become part of a machine it's no
longer just about you so there there
must have been something about that that
she found very attractive and she talked
about you know maybe writing some sci-fi
down the line again she talked about a
project she had going with a friend of
hers but none of that really turned into
anything she kept writing television
scripts and I what shows so you know
that's that I did look it up at one time
and I I forgot to write it down no that
was a surprising thing they weren't like
sci-fi shows okay yeah so you know I
guess it was part of the creative
process I guess was what she really was
attracted to now that she also started
getting all these awards and recognition
later on unfortunately she went up with
Alzheimer's and they they didn't really
know about it till she missed one of the
awards things that she was supposed to
like show on that and she dies in 1987
in Hollywood
you know more and more or less on her
own she never had the kids and you know
she was she was remembered by the sci-fi
community and she had a lot of very
important influence you can say there's
there's in the literature out there
there's there's a lot of discussion
about this jira love Jory character this
a woman's sort swordsman and sort of
sorcery kind of things and how this is
one of the very first real you know
living female heroines in the pulp
literature and that has opened the door
for other writers you know like some of
the ones that we've looked at with
Caffrey and it's interesting when she
was he asked about whether she reads
sci-fi she said I don't read much of
that anymore at all but I do like her so
kate mcquean that her stuff is really
interesting and I think that must have
been in the 60s that she was saying that
but this you know the whole notion that
like in the 1960s with a new wave of
science fiction we had to turn towards
emotional life and relationships and all
that well she was doing that back in the
30s and so she is kind of trailblazer
and I think she's it's unfortunate that
she didn't really write that much all of
these are short stories except for a few
novels but what she did write is really
quite quite good I'll mention that that
I actually encountered her work under
the pseudonym when I was when I was a
kid I had the science fiction Hall of
Fame I know if you guys I've ever seen
those lines or three volumes and they
have the first one is all short stories
and then it's like novellas I think and
the third one is short stories and
they're really great stuff so as Lewis
Padgett she has I think vintage season
is Lewis Padgett and maybe know mimsy
were the
Lewis Padgett I think and then maybe the
other one is but in the science-fiction
Hall of Fame you've got these two
stories Lindsay were the borogroves the
one that got turned into the last Mimzy
kind of hard to adapt I think given what
was going on in the story and then
vintage season vintage season is about
these tourists essentially time tourists
and they're travelling around visiting
places where disasters happen or
sometimes you know good things like
Charlemagne's coordination but mostly
disasters and one of them is actually
preparing a big symphony with his
sensorium Harmon Orion I think it might
be called it's an instrument that allows
them to depict all of these things and
they're kind of like connoisseurs of
human suffering yeah and you know what
the best times of the world it's a show
up at the right place so she's got this
incredible imagination that that she's
sharing with heavy I read that story and
then mimsy were the borogroves is about
what happens with a bunch of educational
toys that accidentally had sent back in
time and how they affect these these
kids lives including Alice from but also
a bunch of kids in sort of suburban from
like a 50s California so you know I read
those and I didn't realize that that was
CL Marcus who wouldn't know it and then
I actually got this years ago when we
were still living in Kingston at the
library and I I thought it looked
interesting when I read shot blow and I
was kind of courted after after that way
I read quite a bit of her other stuff
and it's it's kind of difficult to find
much of her work online that's kind of
difficult to find a lot of her work in
other places too it you got over there
the Jerell of jury stories are gathered
in one volume get that and you can't
find it in a lot of places and then
there the North West Smith stories
available as well today's question oh
yeah given what you've got here a lot of
activity or a lot of publishing during
World War two I would have thought you
know they would have been put on
applause I mean that nobody would have
been paying I mean who would have been
subscribing I mean I mean a lot of
relations just so disrupted and so I
mean the pulps you know the you get
sci-fi and weird tales which is poor and
stuff like that fantasy stuff but also a
lot of true crime right and they're
called the pulps because it's the super
cheap paper and they a lot of stories
quite frankly are very good so but they
haven't taught so merit better paper
yeah it's the decompose No yeah so I
mean if you were a writer unless you got
some job with like the army propaganda
board or something like that you'd have
to find somebody to make a living right
so yeah they probably had an incentive
to keep on churning stuff well but the
question is well what was there really
an audience of paper I guess you know if
you think about it
world war ii did get us out of the
depression so in a way it increased the
buying power of the people that worked
there you couldn't buy certain things
right can you have ration cards like you
couldn't buy tires easily or what else
is rational yeah but I don't think I
don't think it really affected well I
don't think it affected cheap you know
I mean newspapers were sold printing
weren't there are a lot of pulp
magazines sold into the soldiers though
yeah I don't know what the need for
escapism
there yes so so maybe the government
actually like went up some when they
were chief they were at the time there
they were very cheap yeah
and that could be enough girls somewhere
for a schism magazine well I just think
the whole money
I mean maybe right there a lot of
daddies going overseas well yeah
you know but the audience at home was
very female so then the question is it's
the subtracting female readers I mean
yeah well I mean I think sci-fi in
general was way more male female readers
we use Durrell well yeah I mean she
would have been somebody who would have
been appealing to them but you
definitely I think if that kind of to
know ahead of time wouldn't you like by
reputation
I mean you could you can I suppose you
can tell they're looking at the covers
they always have very lurid love grace
but with Jerome jory you've got this red
haired you know worrier maiden with a
sword
well isn't it around the same time that
Wonder Woman hit
the forties I guess she was more - yeah
and people focus on winning and
leadership and American values and
integrated Captain America gets
interesting
well I mean she doesn't she doesn't as
far as I know she doesn't he have stuff
like that
and what she's doing but I mean this
Northwest Smith character
she's an outlaw right it was interesting
that in her stomach because he's within
the solar system the planet
interplanetary outlaw can't go back to
earth so he spends most of his time on
Mars or Venus or in space but you know
he's and it's interesting too because
because earth and in that story is earth
person that story is divided in between
different or in that such stories it's
divided in between a couple different
governments you know I should have just
brought this imminent there's a book
that I just finished reading that one of
those goofy covers it had Northwest
Smith on there goodness but then the
woman from Shambu well oh yeah full of
made fun of my chopper yeah I had a
really really hard time getting because
there's big mix-up they were holding the
book for this so-called book group so I
had it like two weeks that kept rise to
go I'm just looking for this well anyway
so when I got the book she know when
she's checking out she's looking at me
like really it was one of those covers
you know oh yeah because you know I'll
stay cared lady with you know Northwest
smithing is you know that was one of the
big criticisms of the pops though is
that they're they're trashy I mean if
you look at some of the covers it's
basically pornography you have the
covers you know this might have been
appealing at the time yeah it just
yeah but that cover in particular has
been made fun of because they said that
the artist who drew shambleau didn't
really the same criticisms give me a
comic artist now that they don't really
ever see how women's bodies work that's
very nice except set hurt you know which
is a little sneaky yeah you know the
snakes were done well they were just
quick dangly um but otherwise you know
she look nice I think that you know this
isn't something that we've talked about
much but with somebody who is primarily
publishing and happy to publish in the
pulps I guess you could say that you
know it's kind of the finished package
because when you when you like download
you know they have PDFs that you can
give some of these poems
there's always illustrations in in the
middle of the stories and those were
supposed to be kind of part of the
package so I mean we read it in terms of
the text that's on what I thought was
really great you know wonderful writing
and I'm so descriptive and all that but
they you know the average reader I think
was was kind of putting those those
covers the color covers were colored and
then he had the black and white you know
drawings in it like every like fourth or
fifth page sometimes terrible sometimes
really good and then you have the actual
text so in a way it's sort of like I
mean it's not the same as like having
you know TV or something where you've
got a moving picture but it's more than
just the written word you know I must've
been a little confused by the picture I
was in is this a club for the philosophy
of pulp fiction novels well this is this
is a series on speculative fiction so
okay
yeah it's called worlds of speculative
fiction what we do is we spent primarily
about the narrative worlds created by
different authors and then usually I've
got a number of philosophical themes
picked out that are in the person's work
okay talk about the
yeah yeah usually ends up being fairly
freeform because all of us are been here
for quite a while yeah we do a different
author yeah so like the next next month
that's Alice brigde calm fantasy author
gets his characters into the weird
[Music]
different themes and conflict and it's
okay and it's usually what the third
Thursday right second second Thursday
okay so yeah so socio more the author
that we're talking about she was you
know essentially a palm writer but but
really made some important contributions
so so let's talk about some of the
philosophical themes one one is the real
sensuality of emotion in her were shoes
she's unlike a lot of the other science
fiction authors of the time who are
great at describing you know how guns
work or you know interplanetary travel
but aren't so great at depicting
emotions I mentioned that the Lovecraft
was kind of good at that and
interestingly she had a correspondence
of Warcraft she considered Lovecraft to
be one of the Giants of the time you can
see some Lovecraft influence
some of these stories but Lovecraft
probably wasn't very good at depicting
women's emotions and she does a good job
with that and she also does a good job
talking about men so you get kind of a
nice picture of what's going on in the
minds of the characters and that's never
very simple you know they have these
sort of conflicts that they have to work
through and so you know Jerell of jury
isn't just sort of conan with with you
know why you know long red hair and you
know women's after Addyson sort of men's
she's like a fully fleshed out character
who has desires and and sort of
backstory and gets conflicted about what
she's doing is willing to it well in one
of those stories that that's been in
this one juror olive jory has been
captured by this this this guy who's
conquered the kingdom and she has got to
kill in one way or another and so she
she decides to go essentially into the
underworld to find a weapon that can
destroy him and she you know she has to
go through all these different things
that are that are described in very low
crafty ways Nick finally it gets to this
this place where it's called blackouts
kiss because she kisses the black God
and the black God gives her this this
thing that's like something like a
disease a disease of the spirits yeah a
depression I guess you could say or a
despair that goes to the very core of
your soul and she you know manages to
bring it out and and goes up to the you
know the guy who's conquered and forget
his name
Yami or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
and he says give him a sneering tough
guy and she kisses him and gives him
this this this sickness and of course he
and then and then she realizes that all
this time she was so obsessed with
you know taking making sure that he
didn't get the kingdom in part because
she loved it but she couldn't
acknowledge it so she's got it she also
likes to get it a little twist at the
end sometimes in another one the that's
that's here in this which is not a juror
olive jury story or a Northwest Smith no
woman born it's about a famous dancer
and singer who primarily dancer who
who's a terrible fighter and she's she's
saved at least her brain is saved and
they put her into a very special robot
body so already this sounds a little
strange right but it's it's it's unlike
any other robot that's been created
they've got lots of robots at the time
this one is perfectly articulated it's
like a work of art and the question is
will she be able to resume a normal life
given that she she has you know sight
she has the capacity to move around
she has hearing but she doesn't really
have you know the the other senses like
touch or or taste and and she can't
possibly have more talks about this any
sort of sexual relation with any of the
people that she's involved with which
which before had been an important sort
of aspect of her personality will she be
able to you know do the sort of things
that she was able to do will she be able
to be still an artist where is she gonna
be a freak and she she schedules a
performance and the guy who had been
involved with her is very worried about
this he thinks this is gonna lead to her
having a breakdown because the crowd is
so fickle and she is going to you know
be seen us so braved at first and then
everyone's gonna forget her and they're
gonna judge her and she's gonna be
devastated by this while there the twist
is that she's she rises far above and
the question for this character in the
end of the
is not whether she is going to be
psychologically up to the issue the
issue for her is whether she is going to
[Music]
whether she's going to yeah since I'm
not subhuman I'm super human it's not
unhappiness that's bothering me
it's fear I don't want to draw so far
away from the human race I wish I'd
needed that's why I'm going back on the
stage to keep in touch with them well I
can because she realizes that she's
she's stronger than anybody she knows
she could easily be you know like
essentially like a gun on earth given
the new body that she has her capacity
to to dances that she did and the
strength of this this body possesses so
Morris is really good I mean this is
she's writing these things starting in
the 30s she's really good at you know
going into depths of emotions in her
characters something that sci-fi hadn't
really been doing much of at the time
she does it with the very first story
Jean wall so what do you think is is
this something particularly interest
interesting or important you know is
this
or maybe emotions really aren't that
that critical for for sci-fi and fantasy
literature maybe it is more about the
sword fighting shooting people trying to
think of the story it's the one where
them the man has got the crystal cubes
that the two women and he just wants to
marry and he doesn't know which one and
then he and then he gets sufficient of
what it would be to marry both of them
he was such an
sista could do sex determination it was
in there yeah I'm trying to think that
it was like something with the gods
greater than God said yeah anyway having
going generationally South I make a
thousand years into the future to see
what what happened if you married this
young woman had that with a girl child
or if you married this other woman had
the male child and then the world would
either completely if the meal chair
would get it was like this obedience to
remember this thing would be all
obedience and and you know it would be a
really band everything ought to plank to
almost be like a solar system world I
mean like say like you know a United
solar system almost but with with all
these consequences of you know you know
leave
well overlords almost crashing right
what is it so much oppression is it just
was what we learned in obedience and
whatever and then the woman the girl
would have been no moral Marvel you know
the matriarch because no more Wars but
then they kind of lost their whole
identity and as humanity so he was
trying to figure out which one to do
which one went to marry and then it got
really really critical because both of
these children are whom he falls in love
with just knowing their way in their
future yeah but he he just really
because he can see himself any
conceivable these women and it's just
it's really an intensity emotional thing
and I mean you're talking about that you
know I hate to give away the endings
kids anybody wants to read it but you
know there's another theme that I and
it's kind of a classic demon in
literature
another important early science fiction
speculative fiction woman writer you
know Mary Shelley is dealing with this
with Frankenstein the the creation of a
new being who is somewhat you know it
goes beyond what you're expecting and
how do you feel towards it you know in
Frankenstein on the one hand
Frankenstein feels towards the monster
kind of repugnance but also a kind of
love
it's his child but it's also this
horrible thing and and there's there's
something I'm the guy who designs this
robot body for for the dancer that theme
shows up there's another oh yeah so
there's another one of the Northwest
Smith stories there's black thirst there
is this this creature called the åland
arm who has been designed who's been
breeding with designing women for
generations of generations to try to
raise them to the sort of uttermost
level of beauty and it's a kind of
vampiric creature it lives off of beauty
so that's why it's been doing this and
it trains these women or sells them to
various men but not nothing the really
great ones just the lower ones and
there's a sort of like manufacturing the
person motif going on in a lot of her
stories there's even one in here I don't
know if you read this one the one where
it's fruit of knowledge Adam and Eve and
that's same sort of you know sort of
thinking about great discussion of
emotions that are of course but same
thinking about humans as made things as
the products of something else I think
that's a big theme I read all about to
like blast you because I didn't I only
had a week really right up to know woman
okay I don't know it's a good question I
can't imagine that he didn't need so
much why why do you bring them up it's
probably just because we just saw oh
yeah yeah I mean some of the same sorts
of it just made me think of that you
know well about perfection and you know
kind of creating creating relationships
through the like sort of ultimate you
know yeah body type or the ultimate you
know emotional control
yeah man just keep thinking you know and
I want to say anything because I don't
know but there is that one our whole
lines so what say the line but there
isn't a soul yes oh okay yeah you know I
suppose I could mention that there was
like some Pinocchio references to Blade
Runner and that's the same sort of theme
right the how something how something
becomes gender in the human right and
that's kind of what I'm thinking it's
like I mean that's an angel sort of
right that's yeah that's always there
but it's just interesting to me because
it seems like she was very influential
when I was also thinking too of even you
know Lewis's space trilogy yeah what
about well just and her I'd have to
think about this a little bit more but I
think I think the the fact that there
was so much of her work that was read as
other people Oh in and of itself is
interesting to me an exit to this idea
right and so kind of thinking of like
you know we accept that Lewis wrote
fantasy in Narnia your house Chronicles
and that he had the Syfy trilogy and
then of course he had philosophical
explorations and books about
Christianity and the amp universe and
yeah and he was a medievalist so he was
somebody who drew from many influences
yeah and so I'm you know thinking as
you're talking through it not having
read those stories but only what you've
been sharing with me as you've been
preparing for the lecture you know sort
of what was interesting and just kind of
thinking about that I don't know where
my thoughts going yet but it's you know
it's just it's something that we accept
I think more readily from some authors
than form others
so why wouldn't she be able to you know
infuse emotion as much as swordplay or
anything else and why wouldn't she be
able to like yeah explore you know
however or whatever person she was
writing as what makes for the ultimate
being and you know you know I think part
of it was you know the hopes at the time
were a lot of the stories were designed
to arouse emotion right but they weren't
depicting emotion all that much maybe
you know maybe more in some other genres
or the pulps that the true crime you
know but it was usually kind of
stereotyped well the close to like they
tended to be titillating in ways that
you know I mean even like the whole
tradition of like lesbian Pulp Fiction
there always was the wayward girl who
kind of like fell off the tracks and
then she got entangled with the woman
yeah and then some guy you know likely
played football or something would come
along and see from her like a witness
yes you know but that was like every
single lesbian Pulp Fiction story was
that yeah that was the type and so you
know the sci-fi Pope's I mean they were
you know from what you're saying
especially with the ones that she
published there was that kind of
titillation factors yeah like we're
gonna make the most you know perfect
woman know so let me read you two things
from one from Sean blah than one from
black there's this is just a bit of how
she's describing the Shan blows is this
essentially Medusa creature we were kind
of joking around about the year yeah
that was how she was depicted in Allah
and and more depicts this as like the
the archetype from which our Medusa
mythology comes that it was not
terrestrial in origin it was from
somewhere else and so she got this
reading these reddish snakes and you
know that that would be kind of walk
pudding for a lot a lot of people I
think but Northwest Smith is is involved
with with her and then here's here's a
passage
more rights so yeah here we go
there was beauty in it the wet scarlet
writhings with moonlit moonlights
lighting and shining along the thick
warm round tresses and losing itself in
the masses only to glint again and move
silver Li along writhing tendrils an
awful shuddering beauty more dreadful
than any ugliness could be but this all
again he would have to realized for the
insidious murmur was coiling again
through his brain promising caressing
alluring sweeter than honey and the
green eyes that held his were clear and
burning like the depths of a jewel and
behind the pulsing slits of darkness he
was staring into a greater dark that
held all things he had known dimly he
had known when he gazed them to those
flat animal shallows that behind them
lay this all beauty and terror all were
a delight in the infinite darkness upon
which her eyes opened like windows pane
with emerald glass and then he goes on a
little bit more in her living cloak she
swayed to him the murmurs swelling
seductive and caressing in his innermost
brain promising compelling sweeter than
sweet his from his flesh crawl to the
horror of her but it was a perverted
revulsion that clasped what it love so I
mean a lot of sort of you know sort of
would call it body descriptive language
in there a lot of plain straight-out
descriptive language that has an
emotional effect and then some sort of
discussion of his emotional state and
what's going on is this creature who's
going to feed on him is making him him
feel and and there's actually a hint in
there that he like sees what what
Mystics had talked about is seeing God
when she is clasping him because his
friend rescues him unfortunately it was
a great storytelling technique but this
perverted revulsion that that class
would have loved that's almost like
theological it's death and so you know
she's working with emotions but it's
sort of like saying you know I this
instrument and then there's an actual
like great musician and he plays this
instrument or she plays that instrument
to use the words you know we
both play music it's not really the same
tournament all right hurry Emily in the
motion is is way beyond what a lot of
the other people were doing at the time
I mean and then to go back to this like
creation thing
so the Elm dinar in this black thirst is
this one creature that's been with
humanity from the beginning breeding you
know women to be Beauty and the Allender
has effectively read all the other stuff
out of the women as well so there's this
where is this sort of summarize so these
women they're gonna vacuous they're
incredibly beautiful they have no
personality they have no like drive or
anything like that he talks about them
as jewels in a setting the main female
character in there is not like that she
actually does him drive she actually you
know wants to do things
that's why she's kind of low in the
status she's not very beautiful even
though she's an incredibly you know
gorgeous you know in relation to it so I
would say women in this harem that the
åland has been been breeding she's
unremarkable as far as appearance but
the Islander is interested in her
precisely because she has something that
he thought he'd read out she's got some
personality and that she's one of things
in Northwest Smith she tries to get him
to she recruits him essentially so that
theme of you know the creation of
another yeah Britt to be so beautiful to
evoke such powerful emotion yeah it was
going through I mean he was just about
right northwestern is almost killed from
the yeah from the emotional you know
thing of just looking at the beauty of
these women and there was the other
story word that were the guy goes into
the dead
and then he's Gibson's in this big
bubble did you read that one yes and
then and then he sneezed meets but
somehow when he gets in there his the
creatures are so revolting because
there's so different like these one-eyed
sluggish looking things yeah falls in
love with this woman but they see each
other through what they think they see
okay and then in the end you know they
see each other for who they are and yet
they're still in love because their love
transcends all the physical yeah
parameters that we think is its beauty
or not I mean I think it was the second
straight nurse to me that was again very
emotional you know like bossy of love
like what is that yeah are there
different kinds of love maybe like
there's love of you know the ancients
typically talked about there being love
of the body and long in the soil right
and one of the body okay that's nice you
know that leads us to have sex all that
sort of stuff and but it you know
somebody gets old and how you don't love
them anymore
you're like well I'm not such a great
body you know of course if you're
growing all of them they can also like
turn to you and say hey yeah one of the
soul one of the soul transcends that
well that's what that was about
yes it was like I said of one I'd like
you know she uses a lot of Simplot of
symbology lot of snakes worms red hair
yeah I mean it's it's pretty Universal
at all those characters the North West
myth is a big strapping guy but the
women are all the same no matter they
all red hair they all have this really
white skin they also kept look kind of
sneaky thing going on it's just very she
has a lot of love and reversal symbolism
in her writing to whoa you know that I
mean in that author
afterward um I think that's something
that she she talks about like cramming
her head full of stuff and then letting
the unconscious you know do its thing
you know so I think that makes perfectly
she describes women body always the same
in every you know everything so it's
it's I don't know she just except for
what except for one moment zero
sure she has the red hair she's right
here which is she
an active agent who's you know carrying
a sword
oh yeah but she's I mean she's somebody
who's doing something she's yeah she's
she's the you know sort of world leader
for entire little country in France
supposedly set at 1,500 people putting
out this couldn't possibly made sense
you know it could have made sense for
maybe 1250 but not 1,500 but I think GRL
is different they're different she
doesn't have descriptions of them
physically very yeah character-wise
seven you know another one of the things
that I thought would be interesting to
talk about is this motion like going
beyond the limits the imaginable and
twenty another genuinely alien she I
think she is pretty good at that making
her aliens really different from us not
just sort of like you know green skinned
human beings running around doing their
thing the åland hours another you know a
good example of that
he's a goopy monster who's been with us
from the beginning and there's different
ones on different planets and again I
mentioned Lovecraft I think is an
influence on her she has a lot of sort
of Lovecraftian terminology in this she
was also very interested in talking
about like the unimaginable
inconceivable I think she's trying to do
that but not just in terms of horror but
also in terms of like beauty in terms of
sexual attraction is that kind of like
the tide like well you should probably
explain that because I don't think
everybody you explain it better than I
would but I mean it's so but I was
before her time right writing going
yeah but he's in France yeah because I
was thinking like some of the
descriptions and again
read it so it's not fair to really take
up too much time with this but it felt a
little bit like French naturalism and
the way that she was describing the
bodies and the color and then some of
the descriptions of the aliens felt like
it was sort of you know I was thinking
of like we ceman and like the lava right
the decadence and the whole sort of horn
ain't a'no sub everything yeah and then
I don't know there's something about the
description when you were just when
you're reading the passage with like the
green eyes and the flashing and stuff
and it just no it felt a little let me
be ties over the top right with
everything it's like the ties is
primarily interested too
but times more about a philosopher who
could be a novelist than an actual
novelist yeah you know George Matai was
was a French philosopher drawing out a
lot of different sources very interested
in what we can call limit or
transgressive experiences so he talks
about there being you know the things
that we can't look at directly like dad
or the Sun or or or sex I mean it was
wrong about that because I mean the porn
industry is huge but at the time I guess
he can't but these things that we yeah
and and the solar anus and you know
things like that so he's very interested
in pushing the envelope
he's also interested in like trying to
figure out what was going on in the
sacred and I think in part because he
was he was really interested in what
would be vital what would be really
living and this is something you see in
the decadence to like our society is all
you know boring how do we break out of
these yes change was drilling tortoises
so they can't walk it's Barry
yeah yeah I mean what it would bataya
enemy influence at this time in American
some I don't think so yeah
probably more like like I'm a new wave
of science fiction in the 60s and 70s
yeah I mean who would've been
influencing this on the other side of
them yeah I mean when you mentioned to
the VAM prism and of course that made me
also think if we smile and move on some
of the other like or yeah I guess that
that the figure of the vampire was
something people were playing around
with a lot it's interesting because in
the story she you know she kid she's
kind of joking with the main male
character and say no you think I'm the
vampire huh you know so there's there's
kind of sort of the I'm not really that
kind of vampire that you're thinking
about you know but if she comes from a
race of Medusa's that eat you up
essentially show you God in the process
I mean that doesn't actually sound a lot
like the time eNOS I don't think it's
influenced at all by the time
historically but that makes a lot of
sense yeah and I suppose some of the
other stories but similarly
I have that sort of thing I mean one of
the ones that to change that so I
mentioned vintage season vintage season
you've got again aesthetic experience
these people who are traveling in time
and they go backwards and they all have
to like take a pledge not to mess
anything up and there's a really
interesting discussion in there about
whether it's it's possible to actually
change history or not so the story
invention season this guy he's got a
villa he's renting it to these three
people he wants to make as much money
out of them as possible they're there
for the the vintage season they're
really kind of weird exotic they you
know they're they're super graceful he
actually he's married he starts falling
in love with one of the women named clay
out and she introduces him to you know
some of the stuff that they're they're
there they find cool and it's all very
much like the decadence you know
smelling things that are you know smell
corruption and yet beauty at the same
time and you know kind of make you sick
but also kind of make you excited
all in all that sort of stuff that was
being talked about by the whole decadent
and dandy so the reason why they're
there is because there is a meteor
that's gonna hit the earth and it's
gonna mess things up pretty bad and
after the meteor is going to come with
blue death which is like the black death
elite I guess even worse and they're
there just to sort of savor what's
happening and they're gonna leave
they've they've already been inoculated
against it and they're gonna leave and
then move on to Charlemagne's coronation
and and so they're like you know these
are the beautiful people only not just
the beautiful people of our time who
have lots and lots of money and
resources and can go in all the places
that we can't go and we're just you know
the best hired help or backdrops they do
this throughout all time and so the guy
who's Oliver is talking at the end and
he says I'm getting it now wait
I've been trying to work this up you can
change history you can I know you can
collect some [ __ ] I promise not to
interfere you all had the promise does
that mean you really could change your
own past our time it says can be laid
down as pad again you looked at all over
thoughtfully yes the past can be changed
but not easily and it changes the future
too necessarily the lines of probability
are stitched into new patterns but it is
extremely difficult and it has never
been allowed the physio temporal course
tends to slide back to its norm always
that's why we it is so hard to force any
alteration we don't change history
Wilson if we changed our past our
president would be altered too and our
time world is entirely to our liking
there may be a few male content's there
but they're not a lot of the privilege
of temporal travel and so you know what
you've got or these people were
essentially living off of history
savoring all the really cool bits that's
throwing all the stuffed whale at the
husk boy that's almost like you know
more decadent than the decadence that's
some way and that's part of what she
imagined you know so you know this theme
of taking an aesthetic position on life
versus involvement Geryon jor-el
Northwest myth these are people who are
involved these are people who are you
know changing things or taking action
but you have these other people who are
just purely you know they're not purely
detached in the sense of being
unemotional they're they're an
experience every emotion but and safe
distance so that's kind of an
interesting oh yeah we can we can raise
questions like if you could if you could
do that would you do that
you could be in position to travel
through history but you can't change
anything you can only just sort of
appreciate what's going on
would it would it turn you into
something jaded after a while
that's pretty in particular everything
is pretty typical to their another story
and there were both time travel of the
guy who just lives life to the ultimate
he can he has nothing else to do so then
the invent that tend to do be that
strengthen terrible thing and he keeps
going then he keeps coming up against
this woman and with the smoky eyes let
me find the figure thought that that's
somebody that you know they're friendly
yeah but all these times come together
them yeah so that would be just the
opposite of not being above this this
guy was just totally in a whining
every experience you could possibly have
and get right down in there yeah you
know the other time travel the story
that matches mimsy were the borogroves
and that comes from a Lewis Carroll Paul
Wright the Jabberwocky
mmm-hmm so that's one that was written
as low as Patrick then I think won an
award or something like that of some
sort it certainly got incorporated in
science fiction Hall of Fame and here's
the story is that way way in the distant
future
some guys experimenting with time travel
and he takes a bunch of his old kids
toys that are educational toys for like
super advanced kids way way in the
future and he puts them into the
time-travel thing to send him back in
time and see you know if he can like
bring them back into the present and he
screws it up and so these toys like
getting scattered and some of them wind
up with Alice of Lewis Carroll Looking
Glass and some of them wind up with
these these two kids who find that like
a river that dried you know creeks or
something like that and what these toys
do is they're educational toys and so
imagine the educational toys that we
have in the present just like you know
I've dumped many many generations from
now they make your kids much smart and
they develop their brains and so they're
developing parts of the brain that we
don't we don't actually use and tap into
so these kids are becoming incredibly
smart but not incredibly smart like
taking in lots of information rather
like seeing how time works and how how
the whole matrix of the universe can be
visualized or things like that services
the things that you see like Buddhist
mandalas playing around with right if
you look at those or you know some other
things along those sorts of lines it
that people are trying to visualize
that's what's happening to these kids
kids are in a malleable state Lewis
Carroll talks to Alice and agrees to
write down what she has to tell him
verbatim and what she does is tells him
the general argument the Jabberwocky is
actually sort of a you can read it write
a code about how to travel through time
she's figuring not and so the kids when
they actually find the Jabberwocky they
they figure out what the code is what
with the you know the slithy Toves are
yeah you know the Worple blade and that
snicker-snack and all this other stuff
you know and what mimsy were the
borogroves with me and it ends with the
dad know because the toys were taken
away hit a certain point the dance
starts to suspect something's going on
with my kids she takes them to a
psychologist it says what's going on
with my kids and the psychologist you
know finds the toys and and the toys are
with the psychologist you can't really
figure out what they're doing but the
damage has been done the kids are now
like advanced way beyond where all of us
are and the kids like walk through a
portal in time that's that's the last
the dancies of them or the psychologist
or anybody else and again travel back in
time in a way it changes history right
because but but it changes it to a
history we already don't so it's not
changing our history it's sort of
explaining how our history came to be
our history may be difficult to find the
police's even want to go because they
have your arrival times yeah after a
while it's a lot of redundancy right it
sort of like Roubaix defeats could be
easy and then this happens
this intolerance creates this strength
in this conflict no be cool to see
moments of discovery yeah but you
wouldn't want to be desensitized so like
the odd wonder of a moment of discovery
either and if you see like 13 miracles
you know just like imagine that were to
know of one yeah you know I think it one
practical problem that almost nobody
ever really thinks about it is you would
not be able to upset anybody
yeah I mean you'd have to either like
have a universal translator like they do
in Star Trek or a babel finish like
Hitchhiker's stuff well there's a Star
Trek universe I mean Babel Fish is a
thing right we talked about that that's
pretty amazing
so we could take that and then you know
in a snack that would be the other thing
to you because you would kill it buddy
yeah I mean this one they get inoculated
right but imagine the shots you'd have
to have to go through history and not
get sick yeah it's gonna take this and
yeah sure would be fun well you would be
interesting to see the actuality I would
have supposed to our interpretation of
it overtly you know that would be
unfortunate yes because you know history
is stripped the tour at the end of the
story detail yeah about an event but you
see the actual event rather than the
story from the winner of the loser's
Schneider or other oh that gets attached
over the years to see the actual event
as opposed to the tale that's been told
over the years it says somebody's
narrative yeah yeah I mean the stuff
that we possess besides narratives are
some things like archeological artifacts
right so you know we sometimes get that
stuff but that doesn't tell us more than
just
in the story - and even that's the
narrative that the archeologists this
about we do things we'd be able to
recognize if we are in historical
situations we'd be able to actually
recognize that like this thing that we
we've called the historical event is
taking place along in the time right now
I don't know you know we've made we made
commitments as human beings when we are
going to call things what we are going
to do we just yeah like that's a
telephone because we all made equipment
at one time that's what it was going to
be so I don't know how that would all
work with it's already ingrained in
there's a fun things like let's say you
were there at the signing of the
Declaration of Independence you could
probably could identify that yes but but
some of these battles like if you didn't
know exactly where it was analyzed yeah
man for an example so Charlemagne you
know Charles the the great the giant
among men he was like 6 foot 2 I'm 6
foot 3 you know so I would be if I
didn't know any better I'd be going back
and expecting to see this gigantic guy
who's you know real badass killing
killing people everywhere Saxons on one
side Saracens led the other he probably
wasn't that much to look at it's just
that everybody else you know everybody
everybody dirty yeah well yeah I mean
it's they wanted if you could go back
and see Oedipus would you be primarily
interested in the road
everybody else's just be like oh that's
you know true yeah
I mean when I know it was you know Helen
of Troy but I'd be like oh my god this
beautiful woman whatever see so that
your writer then maybe we'd go back in
time and you go back and look at things
like the Lost Colony in Virginia
yeah you find out what happened Oh swim
in well I mean we've was when it comes
to philosophy we have lost probably at
least three-quarters of the literature
that we know about from just just from
Diogenes their teeth lives of the
Philosopher's were inconsistent this
what everybody wrote like some of these
philosophers we like Epicurus for
example I think you're one of the most
prolific authors in antiquity we have
five works of his and that's only
because davon is rarities too for them
and wrote them out by hand in his book
if he had done that if you would have
any sympathy second most prolific author
probably we have nothing just fragments
in other people's works it would be and
now we might go back and get those and
we'd be like well it wasn't very good
I understand why nobody saved got
destroyed
maybe yeah well there's a lot a lot of
that and we might be lucky and quiet
some of these things you know there are
those Scrolls at Herculaneum and first
and then they thought of it managed to
screw up something but now we actually
know how to unroll them right and so
remaining cool stuff so that could
happen you know the Dead Sea Scrolls
duck down 10% of what they rejected yeah
you know the biggest problem is for like
excavation in a lot of these places that
people don't want you digging under
there their houses
you know there's all sorts of stuff
wrong but you're not allowed to do you
know in most these places so who knows
what's down there you know and I
understand why they don't want you to
dig maybe maybe you'll collapse their
place also once you find Antiquities
then all of a sudden that's oh no really
so I mean cousin Trace that was a thing
to ever you can't even find antiquity
Crete this is our Hiram it takes it over
and that's kind of it and you can't do
anything with it so they don't know
anything to see what happens in
Singapore in some ways because they run
out of space to go up so they're
building down you know it's the the
reason I know this is because they're
actually building an extension to the
campus for the Yale and the Culinary
Institute both have satellite campuses
there and they're building down for like
housing and help her go very far like 30
40 stories just Wow they would have to
pour to keep the seed at the water you
know there's a creepy part and if
something happened just the pumps it
don't work
yeah well let's talk about the last
thing because we run out of time in the
library runs this out so collaborative
and and pseudonymous soon anomalous work
it's kind of funny that a lot of what
she's she's got is published under
somebody else's name there's other
authors have done this Kierkegaard you
know a great example but he did it in
park there's two things two things you
can do when you do it that way you can
like argue as yourself which is what
Kierkegaard actually did in some cases
and you can say stuff that you
might not get away with otherwise right
she's not doing either of those so
what's it all about
I mean she is publishing with her
husband they're writing these things
together she was to the publisher just
said you can just take a world war ii
period a lot of authors are probably
dispossessed I mean just go on I'm not
going to be so good right so by
publishing your attic sort of more to
the steam you make it look like yeah
normally we got these 10 authors when
it's really two offers that's actually a
great idea you know if you wanted to
like start a movement or something this
is a again would be sort of like what
character Gary's doing you have a couple
people discussing your ideas but they're
all you what happens in the inter inter
universes it happens there sister it's
writing under one name the brothers
right yeah yeah as lock and demosthenes
yeah everybody out who's who
yeah that's that they look 300 years
it's really tough well I never himself
writes his stuff and that changes his
his name not changes persona that was
what he looks like
another people so that there's a point
in there where he's quoting from
themselves
I think in the second or the third floor
people are like who are you to you know
bring that up
I wrote it yeah I was gonna say it some
future point you may want to vary from
your format oh yeah yeah and take a
movie when it becomes available like
like Eleanor 2049 and do it is sort of a
maybe you want to get done there's no
wait I mean but yes you always know but
I mean now you would basically say
wherever comes yeah read what you want
in advance but you're going to
experience it at that but we're gonna
break I mean we're gonna stop but see
there's so much in that movie I think
that bears rewatching processing
whatever but to do it as a group and to
say where did that come from and I mean
in what is he saying
ever discussion because I think yeah
it's it's a goldmine
I mean not to speak on what movie but
that one is just when we some of us have
seen recently and there's a lot there
yeah and and there's so many movies we
didn't do yeah well that's what I think
quite frankly I mean we could have
separated out into pieces we'd have to
get the library I think that would be
something we do in there I mean DVD or
something but yeah I'd say ok come in
certain seeds right I'll cue there will
be a certain scenes yeah different
format that would I think a film a film
discussion group would be super cool
yeah especially if it's building off of
like exactly what you're talking about
the kinds of things that we've already
discussed with great interest
I mean it would be it would be really
interesting in some ways to like even
compare different versions of some of
these stories this late runner was just
really took off from the first owner
[Music]
because you seen the original so it is
an extension yeah but I mean they took
that they took that's the theme so deep
much deeper than they did the first one
so much richer with all the worry right
now is that it's not making enough money
so that baby
nobody'll make another one Wow because
Hollywood doesn't like it when you spend
lots of money that would be really fun
to do that yeah there's something to
propose for maybe 2018 in addition to
this is what you're thinking yeah that's
not a bad idea
yeah okay I think I think we do continue
with the focus on the forest
yeah well and I've gotten a lot of no
we're sort of like totally into
aggression lab but and that's fine with
me because I don't actually have much
more to say about more myself but I've
been you know since we've been filming
these I've gotten a lot of people
weighing in with comments people are
ticked off probably do not do Island
there's a few other people who they're
like you should do this or you should do
that and so that you know this is coming
here obviously some others as well well
I mean you know Starship Troopers
a good one to do although the movie
really diverges and it's song from and
that was when Heinlein really was
intellect of military
starship troopers managed to kind of
turn it on its head
oh look at the irony I didn't know yes
well there's good discussions and start
your cruise about what makes a citizen
yeah
and whether it's okay to you know use
violence in the way that they are and
who started the war and yeah yeah
there's so many great movies I think we
could do you know I mean it's kind of
fun too because they just keep thinking
how about the Blade Runner because it is
I mean that would be oh and I'm not
gonna but that would be like six or
seven hours of total right if we were to
kind of take it apart and stop oh you
know but we was 2049 because it's like -
so you know but if we were to do like I
mean I'd be like I'd be like a date cuz
here's everything no no like right
barnacles Hagel how's your design right
yeah so if we were if we just did Blade
Runner like half an hour at a time and
did like a deep dive into each one like
you know that way people could see it
and really just kind of like take it
apart and we did some scene breaks where
like this week or this month on this can
we started with the first one today we
ended with 2049 we could actually do
that because it would be in DVD
theoretically people everybody could
rent it well you were right there you
could sort of go to a point and just say
you know I stopped at this number that's
a great idea it's more apparent
legionary yeah no you're right it's more
participatory yeah like a close reading
of a film but doing it section at a time
I do want to say something about so we
saw I believe in our 2049 Tuesday
well no here's a theory thing cheat day
you definitely want to see it the
theater yeah it's it is important yeah
because
can go to one of those theaters with the
dreamland receipts so that your life
[Music]
because there's so much like in some of
the scenes like the landscape and also
walk because you want the sound system
that they have at home because they're
like you know more and the time travel
issue gabab Gabaldon's Outlander those
guys Gabaldon's Outlander series does
the time travel and the attempt to
change history doesn't work can you
change history sure you know there's
this theme of like changing things in
general I mean first the Caleb green
what was that once where they're
changing little bits of the world each
time again lay the patent they got Terry
Terry yeah okay TV TV adaptation of it
but the book itself is great because the
idea is we're gonna like make things
better we're gonna tweak things so you
know when you go back to history maybe
less brutality less
and every time that you know every time
that we'd tweak things we somehow screw
it up even more
all these unintended consequences come
about and lathe of heaven it's like in
it's moving from president to president
to present and they ended up with
everybody they get rid of racism
commence just got great skin you know
and all distinctions have been effaced
and nobody is really human anymore you
know it's just our subconscious telling
us through all these different genres
that we shouldn't be messing with time
travel they're made unfortunately
transition for us yet but you know it it
is interest in them in science fiction
we have so many so many big sort of
technology themes that are getting
played around with not just science
fiction in terms of these books but also
in terms of like the show's like okay
about so one of the key themes in Blade
Runner is okay what about you know
things that are human but not really
human how do we treat them saying this
you of the last funeral same issue and a
whole bunch of things and then what what
about when they decide they don't like
how they're treated but however they not
human see that that's the question
they're only human because we say
they're not just like black people are
human because we say they weren't
they're government in every single
consequence except that we want to use
them for all purposes no you're
different I mean I'm not saying subhuman
but they're different whether they're a
chance they were designed it was
specifications to fit of purpose yeah
well I'm engineer is the same we can
save weather I mean we're not no
engineered there's I mean you know
whatever parents come together but I
mean yeah they were specifically
engineered like Hitler and is you know
this is the same every statement really
is really like central sort of parallels
that's not what that's so original so -
sister well in the Star Trek next
generation the Explorers on data
oh well we should be punished now I
think because it's 8:30 and I'm the
library you know it's gonna be closing
soon so thanks everybody for a great
discussion happy that everybody would
came while you talk about more because
she's really great I think else
breakdown spring here yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]